now to ukraine where a russian missile
attack on the city of odessa over the
weekend could threaten plans to resume
grain shipments from the port a
disruption could have huge implications
for the world's food supply this comes
as the brutality of the war there
continues to take a toll including on
americans who travel to ukraine to fight
holly williams has that part of the
story
luke luzition originally from new jersey
and brian young who came from california
were killed in action this past week in
eastern ukraine
american volunteers
they'd signed up to fight here with
ukrainian forces battling against
russia's invading army there is a good
sight and evil side so they fight for
good colonel ruslan was their commanding
officer yes i'm professional military he
told us lucian was injured by russian
tank shelling and as young went to help
more fire killed them both
why did they volunteer to come to
ukraine
i asked brian once in air and he replied
sir if we americans don't help you
winning this war the next step of russia
will be knocking to our doors
we got the call from
state department
letting us know that look at that
at their home in calabash north carolina
losician's parents kathy and george are
struggling their 31 year old son has
left behind two young children of his
own
i tried to get him to come home many
times he said he couldn't leave his
friends and then it turns out that three
of them died trying to save him
and that's
that's very difficult that's even more
difficult to learn that
why was he motivated to come to ukraine
it was you know david versus goliath and
you know he was he was ready to stand up
and fight for the little guy
ukraine's president vladimir zelinski
has called on foreign volunteers to join
his country's struggle against moscow's
bloody invasion
and thousands have reportedly come here
including many americans but the state
department has warned u.s citizens
against it
colonel ruslan told us brian young had
experience in the american military and
was a capable machine gunner he
perfectly knew what what he was doing
you know a good soldier their remains
are now waiting repatriation
two americans have also been captured by
russian-backed separatists in eastern
ukraine and we understand they're still
being held there for anyone thinking of
coming here this is a very dangerous
conflict
nate
wise words holly williams in ukraine
thank you